(light music)
- [Announcer] This Great Big Story
is made possible by
Lexus, experience amazing.
(light music)
- The Harvard Brain Bank is one of
the largest brain banks in the country.
At the moment we house
approximately 5,000 brain specimens.
(light music)
My name is Sabina Berretta,
I am the Scientific Director
of the Harvard Brain
Tissue Resource Center,
which we affectionately call
the "Harvard Brain Bank."
Our mission is to collect brain specimens,
store them, characterize them,
and then redistribute them
out to investigators across the world.
They do research on the human brain,
and in particular on large number
of neurological and
psychiatric brain disorders
such as schizophrenia, bipolar disorder,
Parkinson, Huntington, and many others.
The Brain Bank never sleeps.
We have two sets of people
that are on call 24/7.
We have a very limited time window
from when the person passes away
to the time we need to be
done with this whole process.
- So this is gonna be your first
brain late at night, right?
- I know, first late-night brain.
- We have to do it in less than 24 hours.
Our courier will bring
it to McLean Hospital
to the Brain Bank.
- [Male Dissectionist]
So just put it out here,
so we're gonna take it ourselves.
- There will be a dissectionist
ready to dissect the brain.
(light music)
That involves separating
the two hemispheres.
One of the two hemispheres is put
in a solution that preserves it.
The other hemisphere will be
dissected in thick sections
and also will be frozen.
We are not even close to understanding
a lot of what we take for granted,
our thoughts, our instincts,
our feelings, our emotions.
There are a lot of questions
we still don't know,
and a lot of our brain function still
will probably be studied
for a long time to come.
A brain donation is,
in a very concrete way,
a gift of knowledge and it cannot be done
without the help of families
and people willing to donate their brain.
(light music)
- Give me a hug, give me a hug.
Yes, I know, good girl.
Wanna do some training?
I work with dogs to train
them to into an MRI scanner
and try to figure out what makes them tick
and what they're thinking.
(light music)
My name is Gregory Berns
I'm a neuroscientist
at Emory University in Atlanta, Georgia.
I've grown up with dogs,
and I've lived with dogs
pretty much my whole life.
One of my favorite dogs had passed away
and in the back of my
mind I started wondering,
did that dog love me in
the way that I loved him,
and that was really the beginning of it.
All of these basic things that we've begun
to sort out in humans,
at least in human brains,
we want to do in dogs.
If dogs can be trained to
go into an MRI machine,
then maybe we could figure out
what they're actually thinking.
So we have a dog in the
scanner, that's Katie,
and she is a veteran of the project,
this is probably about the
15th time she's done this.
(light music)
Just having the idea of,
okay, well let's train
dogs to go in the scanner,
it wasn't immediately apparent how
you would go about doing that,
and MRI scanners are not the
most pleasant environments.
(MRI whirring)
Okay, hey, Callie.
Cool, good girl.
Callie is the little black terrier
who was the first dog to
train for the dog project.
High-five.
I built a simulator of an MRI.
So, this is the simulator that
I built here in my basement,
then we started adding in
recordings of the scanner noise,
which is actually quite loud.
(MRI whirring)
We just started working with treats
and positive reinforcement to see
if we could get her to go into this thing.
That actually proved to be pretty easy.
And then so what we did
was we kind of put out
word of mouth, do you
wanna join this project,
do you wanna train your dogs for an MRI,
and maybe figure out
what they're thinking.
The purpose of this is to go through
a number of exercises
including basic obedience,
as well as how they
react to the obstacles.
When we hold the try-outs
it lets us weed out the dogs
that we don't think
would enjoy doing this.
One of the benefits then
of having more participants
is it gives you statistical power.
You can start to average
dog's brains together
and get a better sense
for what's happening.
I started wondering very seriously
if we could really finally
answer this question,
do dogs essentially like us
just for the social bond,
not about the food.
- [Man] Good boy.
- And what we found was,
looking at the reward system,
that almost all the dogs
had equal responses,
both to food as well as praise,
and even a few dogs liked the praise more.
Things that we were finding
about the dog's brain
in many ways confirmed, I think,
what people know in their hearts about
how dogs behave and why they behave.
And the way I think about
dogs is, in many ways,
they're the ambassadors
to the animal world.
(barking)
They're not that different from
many of the other mammals out there,
and so I suspect that a
lot of what we find in dogs
probably holds true for
pretty much any mammal.
(light music)
- [Narrator] Have you ever
walked out of a building
on a sunny day and had an
uncontrollable urge to sneeze?
If you answered yes, like
me, you likely suffer
from a strange genetic
condition that has remained
unexplained by medical
science for millennia.
And if you answered no, you probably have
no idea what I'm talking about.
Sun sneezing, as it's more commonly known,
is a medical condition called
the Photic Sneeze Reflex.
- [Dr. Louis] Another name
that some have given is--
- [Narrator] Hold on,
before we get into all that,
this is Dr. Louis Ptacek, a
neurologist and human geneticist
at the University of
California, San Francisco.
Okay, go ahead.
- [Dr. Louis] Another name
that some have given is
autosomal dominant compelling
helio-ophthalmic outburst,
or ACHOO Syndrome, but P.S.R. is really
the appropriate name
that we should all use.
Photic Sneeze Reflex
is a tendency to sneeze
when suddenly exposed to bright light.
(sneezing)
- [Narrator] And as
strange as that may sound
it's more common than you might think.
- [Dr. Louis] I estimate
that about one in 10, or 10%,
of all people have this condition.
(sneezing)
- [Narrator] So a lot of us are affected,
but how and why it happens
is not fully understood,
despite the fact that humans have been
pondering it for thousands of years.
In 350 B.C. Aristotle posed the question,
"Why does the heat of the
sun provoke sneezing?"
Aristotle was barking up
the wrong tree though.
- [Dr. Louis] This doesn't makes sense
because heat in and of itself
doesn't cause sneezing.
- [Narrator] Some 2,000
years later the philosopher,
Sir Francis Bacon, also
tried to figure it out.
His theory was that light from the sun
caused your eyes to water,
which then seeped into your
nose triggering a sneeze.
(sneezing)
- [Dr. Louis] It's an interesting thought
but it doesn't make a lot of sense.
P.S.R. occurs almost instantaneously
and it takes longer for
the tear ducts to react.
Furthermore, tears don't cause sneezing.
There's no evidence for that.
- [Narrator] So modern medicine
has come with its own theories,
and it has to do with
the wiring in your head.
- [Dr. Louis] Sneezes
are triggered typically
by irritating things in our nose,
and these are detected by
nerve, the trigeminal nerve.
- [Narrator] And right next
door to the trigeminal nerve
is the optic nerve, you
may have heard of this one.
- [Dr. Louis] The optic nerve
is stimulated by bright light
and sends electric signals to the brain.
Some of that signal can be
picked up by the trigeminal nerve
and misinterpreted by the brain
as an irritation in the nose.
- [Narrator] Which triggers,
you guessed it, a sneeze.
Well, that's the theory anyway.
- [Dr. Louis] Photic Sneeze
Reflex is not a disease,
consequently the medical community
hasn't paid a whole
lot of attention to it,
therefore we know very
little about what causes it.
- [Narrator] But Dr. Ptacek believes
that understanding
P.S.R. could potentially
shed some light on more
serious conditions.
- [Dr. Louis] Epileptic seizures
can be caused by strobing lights,
migraine headache is
precipitated by light.
If we can understand what the mechanism is
that leads to P.S.R.,
this may give insights
into other conditions which actually
are medically important
and represent disorders.
- [Narrator] So, there you have it.
This 2,000-year-old medical mystery
may be worth solving after all.
(orchestral music)
- [Narrator] Imagine remembering
every single day of your
life, all in perfect detail.
For those with Highly Superior
Autobiographical Memory,
or H.S.A.M. for short,
this is their reality.
(light music)
- [Rebecca] I remember
everything that's personally
happened to me since I was born.
- [Narrator] That's Rebecca Sharuk.
I was fascinated by this condition,
so I called her up to find out more.
(phone ringing)
Hi, Rebecca.
- [Rebecca] Hi.
- [Narrator] How are you doing?
- [Rebecca] I'm doing all right.
It's a very wet Saturday morning here.
How are you doing?
- [Narrator] Side note, in
this moment I just realized
Rebecca will remember that this day
was a wet morning forever.
So, you remember
everything in great detail.
- [Rebecca] People can remember
what they did last Saturday,
but I can remember what I
did Saturday 10 years ago.
- [Narrator] What about a memory
from when you were just a baby?
- [Rebecca] When I was twelve days old
I was lying down on the fur
car seat in my parents' car,
and I was staring up
at the steering wheel,
and I thought, "What is that?"
- [Narrator] Rebecca is one
of only 60 people world-wide
to have been identified
with having H.S.A.M.
- [Rebecca] All through my teenage years
I thought that everybody
remembered in this kind of way,
I thought it was completely normal.
- [Narrator] It wasn't until she was 21
when her parents decided to submit her
to the University of California
to undergo two years of testing.
After this, she was officially identified
as having H.S.A.M.
Since memories can come to mind
unexpectedly any time of day,
a negative memory like this
can make living with H.S.A.M. difficult.
- [Rebecca] Mum was putting
me in this itchy, satin dress
and I was crying because I didn't like it,
and Mum gave me this Minnie Mouse toy,
and I couldn't say anything at the time,
but her face terrified me.
- [Narrator] But on most
days, H.S.A.M. is a gift.
Rebecca can recall happy memories
in moments when times get tough.
- [Rebecca] A good memory
that makes me so thankful
about having this kind of H.S.A.M. memory.
- [Narrator] Thanks for chatting, Rebecca.
- [Rebecca] Yup, thanks, bye.
(light music)